[Music]
hey everyone I'm Ashley Carlson and I
recently took a dream trip for any Star
Wars fan up to Industrial Light and
Magic in San Francisco California that's
the division of Lucasfilm responsible
for the visual effects you see not only
in Star Wars but in hundreds of other
movies there I watched some fascinating
presentations about rogue one a Star
Wars story that revealed a little more
of what you might have missed in the
theater taking them to imprison them in
prison he's taking us to quite why why
and there's a fresh one if you mouth off
the game was the slap improvised the
slap was actually Diego's idea which I
had forgotten until he told me uh
reminded me that was mine um the slap
came from him but the and there's a
fresh one if he mouths off again came
from me
and we changed that up a lot because it
was one of the like Gareth wasn't
totally on board with the slap is I just
do it once so it was all just fun and
games at that point and that's why it's
so important when you're doing a CG
character if if it's a you know a
human-sized character it's so important
to have the actor there on set playing
them while filming is going on rather
than you know on a motion capture stage
at a separate time later on which is
often the case because of all that
interaction and the ideas that come up
and you know the reacting teach each
other it's it's crucial I had no idea
that Diego was laughing what happen or
trying to suppress a laugh it's great
you see just a quarter is mal going up
and there's a fresh one if you mouth off
again
there will be much more from my trip to
ILM on ET online.com so keep checking
back and of course pick up rogue one a
Star Wars story on digital now and on
blu-ray April 4th
[Music]
you
[Music]